we must act now to bring the pandemic
under control all over the world
our vaccination campaign is progressing
fast
we're shifting now from crisis
management to long-term recovery efforts
and next generation eu is the engine of
this recovery avec next generation eu
will transform another continent for the
destiny avenir
numerizono's economy
newfoundland in reality
with our european green deal we want to
lead the way for green and inclusive
transformation of our economies and our
societies
fellow leaders we must make this cop 26
a success we owe it to our children
this marks a milestone in
the renewed eu us partnership and it is
our global first in our efforts to
achieve the decarbonization
of the global steel production and trade
a particularly cruel form of hybrid
threat has emerged
with a state-sponsored
instrumentalization of people for
political ends
and the cynical blackmail
has had just the opposite effect
the whole of europe stands united in
solidarity with liswanya poland and
latvia on this issue
europe will never allow parts of our
society to be stigmatized escaped
and mit in bowen